navas was an die von range nicht so früh
nein nein nein nein nein nein nein
wir kommen zu einer weiteren folge von
den handicap games wir zocken heute ein
sehr schmerzhaftes handicap und zwar
habe ich hier was vorbereitet könnt ihr
das sehen vertrauen denn ich stehe hier
vorne hin
und immer wenn ich sterbe muss sich so
einen dicken bis aus einer fucking
ekligen zitrone nehmen und essen und
runterschlucken wahrscheinlich auf roma
dort entsteht gesagt was gesagt oh ja
und es sieht gut aus
wohl gemerkt habe ich glaube ich ihr
gesagt oder wenn ich sterbe wenn ich
sterbe würde ich sagen wenn ich sterbe
muss sich da rein weißen und ich bin
nicht mehr an maxis pc also ich hab
keinen keinen keinen krassen vorteil
mehr
ich habe zwar noch ein ping
seltsamerweise kann ich ihnen aber nicht
nutzen also ich hab nix trotz gutem ping
ich habe hier mit meiner leitung ich
habe diesmal ausgetestet 116 abhängen
ich hab mein land kaum eingesteckt 16
abhängen und die teenies scheinbar
missgeburt nein navas was an die von
range und nicht so früh
nein nein nein nein nein nein nein
oh mein gott ich hoffe da hinkommt wie
habe ich das überlebt
roca wissen die lexus eltern ein
ein herz wie geht es schon los
ich denke und ich gehe voll ab alter
[ __ ] my life re okay leute sport
gesprochen
wie kann man sich ja durch schlechte
träume sind dick sein so groß naja ist
nicht so hinaus gut na ja wo bekommt
richtig schön hier
wenn wenig analysiert sehr erotisch an
ersten aber ich kann es schaffen kannst
du dich halten muss meine route dann
übrigens keine ahnung was da los ist mit
meinem pc ich bin ich bin zurückgekommen
und seitdem geht hier irgendwie ein
bisschen die kacke ab also keine ahnung
das ist ein bisschen am lech ist der
zeitpunkt gekommen einen richtigen pc zu
nehmen muss aber ich habe keinen weil
die scheiß immer wieder so viel kostet
komm runter peter fechter kommt von
seinem laptop da ja na ja ich bekomme
doch nicht spielen alter was ist da los
die gazetten permanente frame einbrüche
heftig warten egal egal juckt mich nicht
es juckt mich nicht so trainieren ich
hasse das mag an microsoft zu leicht
weglaufen finde ich ja okay okay ist
die dicksten nächsten liegst weiter
heftig hälfte ich heftig aber doch nicht
geschäft sehr gut das ist sehr gut das
finde ich super
im ernst wie lola wachst du ich hab dich
mit der kartoffel geschlagen
dein ernst ich kann ich doch mit einem
herzen wenn du riechst du hast ich mit
der kartoffel killen
es geht nicht dass wahllos man ja dann
nach meinem alter was war das für eine
scheiße ist das ist eigentlich handicap
heute leute das ist es eigentlich ein
handicap heute ich zock mit lex ich habe
einfach das leck handicap herausgesucht
und es keine ahnung was da abgeht alter
bauer
außerdem arbeite ja das war ein
richtiger schock
also das mit das muss erstmal einer
schaffen heute mit so einer seltsam man
durch diesen mega lief ich jetzt bin ich
wahrscheinlich am herzen
aber der ist irgendwie per nano passt er
für probleme hat wer probleme hat ich
muss erst mal laufen
ich muss erst mal laufen aber vielleicht
kann ich dann snacken ich dafür das
problem ist in welchen frame ein buch
habt wenn ich gerade socke dann ja dann
ist durchaus kaka wir können sie
entspannt ein roboter ist gar kein
problem
und dann auch gleich danach immer dran
denken unser eisen schwert zu verzaubern
bzw
wir können auch mal schauen ob
irgendeiner und equipment geglaubt hat
yahoo
was ist richtig ich poste alters war
wieder super special modus
da war anna und kritiker läuft jetzt
junge herr verläuft jetzt kannst du dir
leiter der bayer team hinter dir ja auch
mann gesucht das ist so unfair
ich habe einfach diese blöden
missgeburten lexa da ist was gott und
dann auch in zweierteams oder machen
ohne witz das kann man das geht nicht
ach ja und schießt auf drei dinge haben
sie doch noch ein sniper aufgestellt
wahrscheinlich alter meine fresse wie
scheiße kann man sein gott ich würde
sagen du musst die throne
viel spaß ich halte ich hoffe es ist für
ordnung was diese folge so ein kleines
bisschen lag ich musste mich darum
kümmern was das ist aber prinzip geht es
heute abend ins gameplay und ich muss
dann einfach noch mehr zitronen fressen
waka waka
der bereich ist erotisch sexy wo wir
sind wir da der moderator ist geht
einfach weiter ich jemals gemacht habe
einfach einfach mit diesem brutalen
mörder alex gough dollar oder auf meinem
pc gta dem bei uns liegt einfach zu
zocken ist nicht wie die leute ist es
nicht wie sie
doch die pappe euro
schwer hatten eisen schwert
wahrscheinlich und wird den scheiß
lexmark der mich runter trust aus alter
wort da fragt das ist unmöglich
kann man nicht andere das geht nicht
okay leute hier musst du jetzt noch was
einlösen und zwar die feinheit zitrone
jetzt langsam wird recht heftig einer
muss ich noch snacken und dann so glaubt
auch mit der heutigen folge durch und
heute last ein leicht gefallen hat ich
werde jetzt so langsam ausbilden wie ich
mir die reinecke und schreibt eure
handicaps für die nächste folge von jack
gentes abwässer beschreibung 30